XIAOWEN XIN: Hi, everyone.
My name is Xiaowen.
I'm the PM for
Anthos multi-cloud.
And I'm really glad to
have the opportunity
to be here virtually
with all of you today
to talk about modernizing and
managing your apps with Anthos.
A pain point that
we consistently
hear from customers is that
they have a lot of legacy apps,
running on older infrastructure,
using older frameworks,
and that have become
hard to maintain.
Customers are looking
for a platform
to help modernize these
older apps, as well
as leverage the modern best
practices for their new apps.
And this is where
Anthos comes in.
Anthos is an application
modernization platform
that helps teams move
faster and at scale.
With Anthos, you can modernize
your apps in place, on prem,
or in the cloud.
You can automate
policy and security
at scale for all of your apps.
And you get a consistent
operational experience
across all of your deployments.
And those are designed
to be deployed
wherever you deploy your apps.
You can use it to build
an application platform
on top that abstracts away
many platform specific details.
The vast majority
of enterprises today
are operating in a hybrid
or multi-cloud environment.
A lot of customers
want the flexibility
to choose different
environments for different apps
while reducing
operational overhead.
Some workloads must run
on prem due to security
and regulatory reasons.
Other workloads
have been designed
to take advantage of some
best-of-breed solutions
from specific cloud providers.
And beyond that, many
customers want their apps
to be able to run on
any cloud and sometimes
be able to simultaneously
run on multiple clouds.
Many customers want
to be able to burst
from on prem to the cloud
or failover from one cloud
provider to another,
or load balance
between multiple clouds,
and do all of this in order
to achieve resiliency
goals, cost savings,
and reduce menu locking.
To enable these hybrid
multi-cloud use cases,
Anthos is highly optimized for
many deployment environments
with a consistent
operational experience that
takes all of them into account.
On prem, we support
VM's running on VMware,
[INAUDIBLE] with Bare
Metal support coming soon.
We interoperate
with a large number
of storage and
networking providers
so that the platform can easily
integrate with your existing
infrastructure.
In the cloud, we integrate
with cloud specific services,
such as load balancers, private
virtual cloud, virtual climate
clouds, and
identity-and-access management.
GCP and AWS are currently
fully supported,
with Azure support coming soon.
And at the mobile
edge, we're partnering
with telecommunications
companies
and providing a
deployment option that's
optimized for the small
footprint, large fleet
size, and the unique
networking requirements
of that environment.
Now, on top of this
distributed infrastructure,
Anthos provides the tooling
and the best practices
built in for all the different
members of your team.
For infrastructure operators,
we provide a unified experience
for managerial Kubernetes
clusters in your environments,
along with the configuration
policies required
to meet your enterprise
security and compliance needs.
For service operators,
we provide a way
to gain visibility and
control of your services,
including traffic management,
authentication authorization,
monitoring, and alerting.
And for developers, we provide
ways to easily deploy and run
modern surveillance
workloads without needing
to learn about the
underlying infrastructure.
All of these
components are built
on open source
foundations, much of which
was first developed at Google.
With Anthos, we put the
LEGO pieces together
to give you a
managed and support
experience for
your infrastructure
so that you can focus on
your unique business logic.
So let me show you in a demo a
bit more about how all of this
works.
We'll first look at some details
of the individual clusters.
And then we'll take a look
at the unified management
experience provided on top.
Here, I have created
four Anthos clusters.
The first one is a
GKE cluster on AWS.
The second one is an
EKS cluster also on AWS.
And the bottom two are
GKE clusters on GCP.
Anthos on AWS just reached
GA status recently.
And we've heard of a lot
of customer interest here.
So let's take a quick look at
how GKE integrates with the AWS
environment.
Under the hood, the cluster
is running as a number
of [INAUDIBLE] VM's in AWS.
A cluster control plane
consists of three VM's that can
be deployed in a highly
available fashion, as we
have it here, across
three availability
zones in the same region.
The other three VM's here
belong to a single node pool
deployed in a single
availability zone.
You can also add in
additional node pools
and put them in
different availability
zones in that same region.
Note here that none of these
nodes have public IP addresses.
For security reasons,
most of our customers
prefer that the clusters
are available only
on an internal
network and can only
be accessed via a VPN
or a similar mechanism.
A lot of customers
have well-established
AWS VPC's that have been through
rigorous security reviews.
So GKE is designed to be able
to install into the customer's
own VPC and stay within
the established boundaries.
From a management
perspective, we're
starting with the foundation
that most customers are already
familiar with.
Just like the
Kubernetes-based apps
that you deploy and manage,
GKE clusters and other Anthos
resources can also be
defined declaratively
in a YAML file which can be
stored in source control.
And they can follow similar
processes like code reviews
and have manual approvals
before deployment.
Additionally, you
can enforce policies
on it using the
same tools that you
use to enforce
policies on apps that
define [INAUDIBLE] YAML files.
For example, here
is the YAML file
I used to define the GKE
cluster on AWS that we saw.
We defined here what
region the clusters
should run in, what VPC to use,
what subnets to use, and so on.
With this, customers
can then layer policies
on top such as to enforce
that only certain VPC's
may be used for GKE clusters.
Now, zooming out a
bit, we've just briefly
explored how GKE integrates
with the native environment,
specifically in the
case of running on AWS.
You may be wondering
how we provide
a unified operational
experience on top
of such a large variety
of cluster deployment
environments.
That journey starts with
a unified authentication
experience.
Many customers have standardized
on a few top identity providers
for their corporate
authentication needs,
such as Microsoft Active
Directory, Okta, and others.
GKE clusters support
OIDC, Open ID Connect,
so that customers
can authenticate
using the same familiar
corporate credentials to all
their clusters across
all their deployment
environments,
instead of using GCP
accounts for some clusters, AWS
accounts for other clusters,
and so on.
Let's see how this works.
Here, I've registered
my GKE on AWS cluster.
But I haven't yet
authenticated to it.
Let's click the Login button.
In this case, we're
using Okta as our example
corporate identity provider.
So I'll enter in my
Okta credentials here.
And now I've logged in.
The process is similar
on the command line
and also works the same way
for other Anthos clusters.
After authentication,
I can now use
this web console to see
information about the cluster.
I can see the nodes that make
up the cluster and information
about each node, such as the
pods running on that node.
Now, so far, we've explored
running GKE on AWS.
That's one option for
running your workloads.
You can also run GKE on other
clouds or in your own data set.
You can attach your own existing
EKS or AKS cluster to Anthos.
You'll soon be able to bring
VM's to Anthos as well.
For example, the second cluster
I have here in the web console
is an AWS EKS cluster
that's been registered
to my Anthos [INAUDIBLE],,
an administrative domain
for Anthos resources.
Once registered, you can run
the same higher level Anthos
services on top, such as
configuration and policy
management, as well
as service management.
With this option,
customers can keep
using their existing
Kubernetes distribution
and can more easily
onboard onto Anthos
while relying on Google
to test and support
the integrated solution.
AWS, EKS, and Azure AKS
are supported today.
And more distributions will
be supported in the future.
Now, if and when you'd
like to move the GKE,
you'll get many
additional benefits.
You'll get a
Kubernetes distribution
backed by the company
that created Kubernetes
and with the most
experience in managing it.
It'll be the same
Kubernetes distribution
everywhere with same networking
and identity [INAUDIBLE],, many
of the same security
features and so on.
You'll get a more
consistent experience
for managing the cluster
in its lifecycle.
Now, switching
gears, just seeing
how Anthos provides a consistent
management experience to access
all of my clusters across
deployment environments,
beyond access,
many customers also
need a way to ensure that their
policies and configuration can
be applied across all clusters
reliably and uniformly.
And this is where ACM, Anthos
Configuration Management,
comes in.
With ACM, you can have all
of your cluster configuration
policies defined in a
central Git repository.
And that will be
synchronized and applied
across all of your
Anthos clusters.
This gives you a way to easily
manage a fleet of clusters
and prevent drift with
continuous monitoring.
Using git as the
source of truth,
you can manage your
configuration policies as code
with the power of
source control,
so you can integrate
code review flows,
be able to easily audit changes,
and you can easily revert back
to previous versions.
Many of our customers use ACM
to apply and enforce policies
like limiting host OS
access, as well as limiting
container refill
access, and shutting off
external [INAUDIBLE].
For this demo, I've
configured all four
of my clusters to
pull the configuration
policies from the git repo.
They're all pulling from
the same git branch.
And they've all updated
to the latest commit.
Clicking to one of them, the
git repo URL is configured here.
And the subdirectory we're
using is configured here.
If I navigate to this git repo,
and then the subdirectory,
I can see the
configuration and policies
that are being applied.
Specifically, in this
cluster directory,
I have a cluster y to
configuration in policies.
For example, we
have a policy here
that requires that all
namespaces have a cost center
label for auditing purposes.
Going back, there is also
a namespaces directory
that defines a few named places
that will be managed by ACM.
For example, in this file, we
create a shipping Dev namespace
with a cost center label.
Switching back to
the terminal, we
see that the shipping Dev name
face has been created by ACM.
Let's see what happens if we
try to delete that namespace.
We see that the namespace
was deleted and then
immediately recreated by
ACM about three seconds ago.
So ACM is constantly
monitoring to make sure
that what's deployed matches
the source of truth in your git
repo.
Now, what if we were
to try to something
that violates our policies?
We saw earlier that
there's a policy requiring
that all namespaces have
a call center label.
If we try to create a namespace
that doesn't have such a label,
this action is denied.
And the namespace
does not get created.
Without cluster configuration
and policies in place,
the next thing we might want to
set up is our CI/CD pipeline.
For this, one simple
option is to use
Google Cloud Build, our fully
managed, serverless CI/CD
platform.
With Google Cloud
Build, you can easily
find pipelines consisting of
arbitrated built steps run
as container images.
They can be automatically
triggered from your source code
repository and run on
Google's infrastructure.
For this demo, I set a
really simple pipeline here
that performs three steps.
First, we do a Git clone of
the Kubernetes examples repo.
Then we update the
service definition
to use a service of type load
balancer instead of node port.
And finally, we
configure [INAUDIBLE]
and use it to deploy the
Guestbook sample app.
Now let's kick off
the deployment.
While that's running, let's
view the progress in the web
console.
Here, we can see the three steps
and the output from each step.
Notice that we deployed
this app to our Anthos
GKE on AWS cluster.
So while your CICD pipeline
can be running on Google Cloud,
you can use it to deploy
to any Anthos cluster,
including clusters on
Prem and in other clouds.
In this case, our
cluster is actually
sitting in a private VPC in AWS.
We're able to access it because
there's an agent running
in that cluster that
reaches outbound
a Google Cloud to maintain
a persistent connection.
We didn't need to
open up any firewalls
or expose any public IP
addresses for that cluster.
Visibility to proxy of
Kubernetes control plane
traffic is currently in alpha.
So this pipeline
is pretty simple.
And it finished quickly.
You can, of course,
include many more steps,
such as steps that build
container images, run
validation, and
unit tests, and so
on all within this
fully managed service.
Let's now move to the Kubernetes
page in the web console.
We can select the
cluster to view.
And we see here that
our guestbook workload
has been deployed.
In addition, our guestbook
service is also running
and an AWS ELB, Elastic Load
Balancer, has been allocated.
We can click into that, view the
guestbook, which is currently
empty, and add an entry to it.
With this Cloud
build integration,
you can build your app once
using our serverless CI/CD
platform.
And deploy it across
multiple clouds.
For customers that
need to build jobs
to be able to access
private resources,
or need more
configurability, we're
also offering a new feature
called custom worker pools,
currently unlimited
beta, where you
can run builds in
your private network
on GCP using VPC
network [INAUDIBLE]..
Now, after we've
deployed our apps,
one more thing we
might want to do
is to be able to monitor them.
Anthos makes this easy with
ASM, Anthos Service Mesh, which
is our managed version of
the open source [INAUDIBLE]
project.
With ASM, service operators
can gain more visibility
and control over your services,
including traffic management,
authentication and
authorization, monitoring,
and alerting.
For this demo, I deployed a
sample online boutique app
a few days ago on my
two GKE clusters on GCP.
With the ASMUI, we can see at a
glance how all of our services
are doing.
We can also drop
into a topology view
to see how the services
communicate with each other.
From here, we can
drill into each service
to get more information
about that service.
We can see any SLO's
we set for the service,
as well as a lot of
metrics for the service,
such as requests per second,
error rates, latency, request
size, and so on.
As of the latest release,
GKE clusters on GCP
can be part of the
same service mesh.
So they can load
balance between them.
And we can aggregate
to the metrics
for the services
running on them.
So the metrics we see here are
aggregated from both of our GKE
clusters that are on GCP.
If we want, we can also
break this down by cluster
to monitor each
customer separately.
For example, let's do that
for this latency graph here.
With this view, we can see how
the services in each cluster
perform relative to each other.
The red line
represents one cluster.
And the blue line
represents the other.
Taken together, these monitoring
and multi-cluster capabilities
make ASM a great tool for
operating your services.
Note, though, that these
capabilities are currently
only available for
GKE clusters on GCP
and will be coming
soon to Anthos clusters
running on prem and
on other clouds.
To wrap up, we just
saw in the demo
today how we can bring workloads
running on other clouds
to Anthos, whether you choose
to use GKE or another Kurbenetes
distribution.
We saw a unified authentication
and management experience
from the web console.
We applied the same
configuration policies
to all of our clusters.
We deployed an app
to a GKE cluster
on AWS using Google Cloud Build.
And we saw how we can
use Anthos service
mesh to monitor the services
running in our clusters.
There's a lot more we didn't
have a chance to cover today.
So check out the other
sessions this week,
as well as our website at
cloud.google.com/anthos.
Thanks for watching,
and stay safe.